the flipped classroom is a new method of
teaching that is turning the traditional
classroom on its head every day
thousands of teachers deliver the exact
same lesson in class to millions of
students every night millions of
students it over the exact same homework
trying to figure out how to solve it the
flipped classroom is turning this upside
down traditionally students listen to
lectures and take tests in class and
read textbooks and work on problem sets
at home in flipped teaching students
first study the topic by themselves
typically using video lessons on YouTube
and then apply the knowledge by solving
problems and doing practical work in
class
modern schools who flipped their
classroom report many benefits one it
allows all students to learn at their
own pace as videos can be watched again
- it's more efficient as students enter
the classroom prepared to contribute
three it enriches the classroom as more
time can be spent on group work in
projects for doing homework in class
allows students to help each other which
benefits both the advanced and less
advanced learners flipping also brings
changes for teachers traditionally
teachers engage most with the confident
students who ask questions
flipping allows teachers to target the
students who really need help instead of
just those who are confident also
instead of instructing from the front
teacher's guide on the side this allows
them to work more closely with
individuals or small groups teachers
that are not great presenters can use
third-party videos to explain the
concept and focus on methods of teaching
that suit their style such as project
work or experiments once video lectures
are made available online teachers don't
need to give the same lecture over and
over again again they gain more time to
focus on the needs of their class
many scholars also argue that the
flipped classroom model promotes equal
learning opportunities as all kids get
the same attention when doing their
homework
currently kids with caring parents older
siblings at home or expensive private
tutors have a clear advantage over those
who don't let us know what you think if
you were a teacher tell us if this model
will be possible in your classroom if
you were a student let us know if you
would prefer learning in a flipped
classroom
you